well first of all how are you feeling
today now that you've had some time by
yourself to let it sink in
yeah it's it's a very surreal feeling uh
this has been something that's been on
my radar for
a year because of the the kylemore mix
of last year so this is like it feels
like kind of like the end of a chapter
it's uh you know it's it's truly like
getting to be like feeling just being
back home and knowing that like that
game is still going on but i'm here and
it's it is it's surreal but um i i
definitely like i definitely feel good
i've had time to kind of decompress it's
uh it's really nice yeah
and so did you think this was gonna
happen i feel like you had such
confidence you were walking around after
your hoh like you were almost
untouchable and then bam everyone just
turned
yeah yeah uh it was definitely i wasn't
i certainly wasn't expecting week three
to be as messy as it was um you know
i've kind of joked it's one of those
things that it's like
nobody can ever take away the mess that
was week three um it's uh
but yeah like i was definitely i was
definitely feeling really good all uh
you know my two of my allies had won
hohs week one week two i won week three
it was an hoh that i didn't necessarily
want to win as much um you know i was
kind of hoping that i might skid just a
little bit over the uh tough sledding
because i i felt i did it's funny
because i felt really good with josh um
i didn't think that i would find my way
up on the block uh with josh so
um
yeah it
i'm i'm so sorry i feel like i rambled i
completely kind of lost track of the
question it's okay it's okay
in big brother usually when your
alliance and best friends
get hoh you feel safe yes were you
feeling safe this week when gino won hoh
and you're like oh it's okay it's going
to be fine it would be different if
someone else had won but yes
definitely no after after knowing that
gino was one of the people who voted to
evict josh and and he was now he was
always on my side i had nothing but
faith in uh in my decision making um to
then uh you know when he won and i kind
of realized all that i was like okay
i've got a week to rebuild my game i
have uh you know i have i can rebuild
relationships i can talk with everybody
um and uh it was just one of those
things but there was still this like air
in the house like things in there it
becomes your whole world everything
becomes so amplified so there was
definitely like there was no uh you know
bygones be bygones kind of uh kind of
feeling so yeah i definitely it was the
right move for gino to make but um but
definitely it was a uh it was a tough
pill to swallow for sure
who do you think was behind the move
telling gino that he needs to
disassociate himself with you in order
to further his game
well um
i've been told that it was summer um
so i i do know that i do know that she
she played a role i think that it was
one of those things i think that that
was a pitch that was done by more than
one house guest i think maybe summer
possibly led a bit of the charge um but
uh i know that there was a few a few
different individuals who were
definitely advocating for that on behalf
of their game and on behalf of geno's
game as well and i do truly feel like it
was the best move for gino
did you ever expect your first hoh to be
chaotic messy like the topic of
conversation i know i know no not at all
it was one of those things like what i
won i was like okay you know nice easy
week here we go like let's just kind of
keep everything even keel um going into
the house my whole approach was that um
you know i wanted people to weed
themselves out very much like i ended up
doing um where people alienate
themselves and then you just have a nice
easy pass like this week was one of
those weeks where a lot of people got to
kick their feet up because i was such a
house target um so uh so no i never
imagined that week three would be as
messy as it was but
it was a it was you know the alliances
were in shambles everything was kind of
all over the place and as in being in a
position of power i figured i kind of
had to try to figure out where the game
was at and the only way you can do that
sometimes is by drawing a line in the
sand uh but i do feel like it was
definitely too soon for sure
what was your logic of putting people up
on the alliances there's people outside
of them you could have chose but you
just went straight for the alliances
which kind of made the house guest be
like do we trust him
yeah yeah no that's that's totally fair
um
so the idea of going uh i i mean i feel
like when you're aligned with people
those are the people who you're sharing
the most intimate information with in
the game those are the people who have
the most to
um they have the most kind of uh
what's the word i'm looking for um
oh my god they're most ammunition like
they have like they have the most
ammunition against you and the savage 7
was one of the more powerful alliances
i'd seen in big brother um it was seven
of the strongest people in that in that
house um all working together and and
because of uh you know the early
conversations with moose and everything
it just felt like it was it was already
kind of turning in on itself so the idea
that was i going to sit back and wait
for somebody else in the alliance to
take a shot at me or you know i go hey
listen i got bit by the paranoia bug bad
um and decided that i would be the one
to shoot first but uh yes certainly in
hindsight i much i should have uh you
know burned a bridge with a relationship
that was much more at arm's length
versus the more intimate alliances that
i had absolutely
seven's a large number so you know that
alliance is never gonna really last so
seven there's a lot like i i'm a fan of
the show you know a seven person
alliance doesn't uh you know doesn't
they were saying final nine i was like
really i don't yeah that that doesn't
seem right so when when all of a sudden
week two i'm hearing rumblings that you
know tea is coming after geno and that
moose would have put up permanent tea
and all of this stuff i kind of figured
that the alliance was already dead so
it's uh to shoot within the alliance and
i i think it was it was already on its
way out the door for sure
a lot of people want to know like how
close were you and moose how did you
guys really know each other outside of
the game like were you in seminars
together or was it just like passing on
campus um so we were in the same program
but he was one year ahead of me uh so we
worked on a few different um productions
together um during our university days
we didn't really have any classes
together but we ran in similar as social
circles where we would see each other at
once in a while um and uh yeah we were
we were acquaintances for sure
and you turned on them so quick it was
that conversation with you steph and
moose in the hoh room you could see that
like the gears were starting to move in
your head you're like oh moose is a good
liar
yeah do you feel bad about like flipping
on him so quickly
no i definitely there was
it was because of the fact that i had
this pre-established level of trust with
moose that didn't have to be earned in
this house like you have to earn trust
and the fact that i knew him outside of
the house it gave me this level of trust
with moose that made my game very
vulnerable where i trusted everything
that moose said i was making decisions
kind of almost solely at times based on
the information moose was bringing me um
and so
in realizing that he was this really
fantastic liar and social manipulator um
it kind of made me re-evaluate like you
know what kind of am i being pointed in
the wrong direction is this you know is
this all smoke smoking mirrors and am i
being used as a tool for somebody else's
game so um i definitely felt like he
posed the biggest risk to my game at the
time and so regardless of our
relationship outside of the house i felt
like he was just the biggest threat to
me and had to try to send him home this
week or last week three that's such an
honest answer and that's a really fair
answer i feel like people aren't
realizing
that logic behind it that like you are
trusting moose because you know him
people are kind of seeing it as
backstabbing so
i respect that but so you told marty
that the only reason you put josh up was
because
he told you basically to do that is that
true or was there some more logic like
was josh on your radar
josh was somebody who was very much not
on my radar um josh was somebody who i
definitely could have seen myself going
far with in the game super level headed
i did see him as an as an enormous
threat he's super smart um very social
unbelievably athletic
so i saw him as somebody who was like
this guy has a absolute chance to win
this game and i recognize that in week
three so like let alone if you get to
week six seven and he's got a full head
of steam um so i kind of thought you
know this is a massive player who could
be a detriment to my game down the road
but when marty was coming to me that
entire week saying you know jo like josh
is coming for me blah blah blah blah
josh would have put me up on the block i
was so happy when you won josh josh josh
i realized that if josh truly was coming
for marty somebody that i trusted there
was a good chance that i would find my
way up onto the block next to marty um
because of our relationship with the
both being from new brunswick and um and
you know we had a really close
relationship so i i kind of figured this
is one of those things it's like why
give them the chance you know he's such
a strong powerful player why give him
the chance to win one and uh put marty
and i up um when i i thought i had the
numbers to take him out when i did but
well your hoh will forever be memorable
how do you feel about that it's gonna go
down in bb can history
that listen it's one of those things i i
set myself up uh you know i i talked
about how i wanted to be a legend in
this game how i wanted to you know i
wanted to be this big player i wanted
people to model their games after me to
come to to go forward and um i think the
whole point of a legend is that you're
never forgotten and good luck for
getting week three of bb can ten so uh
and uh in one way or another i'll check
that off my i'll check that off my uh my
bucket list for sure but um yes no week
three was messy but it was mine
and also
for the past few years on the fourth
week a kyle has went home
yes yes that's what i've learned i
learned that when i got out that it's
the curse of the kyle like kyle never
makes it past week four
what's your biggest regret
biggest regret um
i would definitely say my biggest regret
is not
listening to more people while i was in
the house
and only zoning in on a few key voices
um i think that that just like that
limited my perspective on the house um
you know the way that i see it is if you
have one conversation for 20 minutes
with somebody that you really trust or
you have five conversations in 20
minutes um with people that are out
there in the house and they they're not
in align with you and they have a
different perspective the amount of
information you're getting is far more
with the five people than with the one
but because of the paranoia of the house
and thinking that you can only trust a
few people i really definitely dove into
a few key voices and that was that was a
huge part of my downfall for sure
so call it pride call it ego call it
whatever you want but it uh it certainly
did come to bite me bite me in the ass
for sure
and my last question for you is what do
you want to be remembered for aside from
the hoh aside from the hoh um
honestly i really want to be remembered
for my mental health advocacy it is the
thing that means the most to me um it is
the thing that gave me a bunch of solace
knowing that coming home i was coming
back to a job that i love um coming back
to a field that i love and uh i just
hope that uh you know those those those
final few days when i kind of knew that
the writing was on the wall and that i
was probably going to be leaving the
house unless there was a twist um i
really had a great opportunity to sit
down with people in the house and talk
about mental health talk about uh the
stigma surrounding it and um i really do
hope that people kind of see that uh
that side of uh kyle more the person
versus con more the player and just just
know that to
have that stage was it meant more to me
than a lot of people will ever know
you